power according to a Harvard professor
Rosabeth Moss Kanter is the
organization's last 30 secret it is
however the secrets of success power is
a subject that I think makes many people
extremely uncomfortable they it violates
their idea that the world is a just and
fair place it violates their basic
belief that people can get ahead just on
the basis of their hard work and their
good effort it violates often in often
times what they feel comfortable with
doing in terms of networking or
flattering people or getting control
over resources or all the various
sources of power so the power the idea
of power is I think difficult for many
people to accept and so what we try to
do and what I try to do in my work on
this is to first of all give people lots
of examples of you know from everyday
life and from their own life and have
them in addition to giving them examples
in cases and readings and things like
that so to make them understand the
power is in fact all around them kind of
like air and water and gravity the other
thing which we which I really try to do
a lot is to have them reflect on how
Power has played out in their life and
to reflect on what their strengths and
weaknesses are and to think about
specific strategies and specific actions
that they might take and how they might
be more effective it's slightly more
effective and even slightly more
effective will put them in a very
different place
there are many practical strategies that
people can use to increase their power
within an organization one is to first
of all my mother basically diagnosed who
has power not just the formal power but
the informal power often times it's an
assistant or a secretary or people who
don't necessarily are that high up in
the organization chart but to diagnose
the real distribution of power and then
to figure out how to get closer to the
people with power and get those people
on their side and one could be doing
small tasks that make those other
individuals lives easier one thing could
be not working with them spending more
time with them building social
relationships one thing they could do
would be to flatter them because people
like to think good about themselves and
we all love people who make us think
good about all of ourselves and one of
the best ways to make people think well
of those all of themselves is to flatter
them so that would be three things that
you could do fourth thing you could do
the game power is to figure out what are
some resources unexploited resources
that can be used oftentimes
organizations have budgets that will
permit you to put together a speaker
series that will let you meet people
sometimes there will be resources to do
dinners or lunches whatever those kinds
of resources are that permit you again
to put yourself in the center of of a
series of relationships
everybody in the world
I think understands that organizations
and work life is all about social
relationships and the better
higher-quality more with more powerful
people social relationships ie networks
that you have the better your career is
going to go but people find networking
to be a key or aversive or something
that doesn't feel natural or there feels
contrived to them or something and so
one of the things we try to get them to
do is to say okay who are you spending
time with it's interesting who do you
need to know in order to be successful
given your particular industry and
function and the career that you want to
pursue how might you reallocate your
time in ways that cause you to spend
more time with people who are going to
be useful to you and your job in your
career and less time with people that
you're just comfortable with being with
who are oftentimes who are people who
are very similar to you so they are
sources of redundant rather than non
redundant information and ideas and
social context you really want to meet
people who you don't know very well who
can link you in to different ideas and
different social relationships and
different jobs and different networks
then you're used to to being with so a
lot of what a lot of what my teaching
and power is about is getting people
comfortable with doing things that they
didn't think they could do but once they
do it they find out oftentimes that they
actually can do it and that they
actually like it
your job as a leader is not to be
authentic or genuine or whatever true to
yourself your job as a leader is to be
true to what the situation requires of
you so if you're an entrepreneur out
raising money and you feel discouraged
and you're not sure exactly what you're
doing because that's really the
condition of any entrepreneurs the last
thing you want to do is to go to your
potential job recruits and your
potential investors and to putting it to
potential customers and to signal to
them that you don't have confidence in
your own success
so confidence is contagious if you're
confident in your own abilities and your
own capabilities other people may have
confidence in you and that confidence
then permits them to invest their human
capital or their financial capital in
your enterprise and then you become
successful so you have to be able to
sometimes display emotions that you're
not really feeling and that may be
inauthentic
but it's what success requires
you